Mervin is with us in North Carolina hi
Mervin how are you hey David how are you
better than I deserve what's up a
question for you um I'm trying to make a
decision into cashing out a 401 K I just
recently got out of the bush and I had
to cash out my wife so I had to
refinance their home in order for me to
take some of the equity and take her out
once I did that I ended up with a first
mortgage in a HELOC you've already done
yes already done that
why did you keep the house when you just
sell it well two reasons want to try to
give my boys some kind of stability
during this rough time they live with
you in a sense yes they do and so I
tried to keep some kind of stability
moving so I kept them on the same school
district and all that so my question is
I have a small 401 K they'll have them
said my thinking was to try to cash that
out and pay on to that mortgage now to
be able to okay here's why okay when you
cash that out you're going to be hit
with your tax rate plus a 10% penalty so
what do you make a year roughly about 48
okay so you're in 20 percent tax bracket
plus a ten percent penalty will be 30
percent it's kind of like saying Dave I
want to borrow money at 30 percent
interest to pay down my mortgage right
it doesn't make sense does it no it does
not
yeah so let's just leave that alone get
it invested in good mutual funds and
would you know how much is the first
mortgage payment the first mortgage
payment plus the helicase roughly about
a thousand dollars that's giving towards
your take on first more a month 2930
2930 2001 I calculated
twenty eight twenty eight percent of
your take-home pay I'm talking about
yeah your take home page three thousand
you have a thousand dollar payment
that's thirty three percent
well I'm paying a little extra on those
on both the mortgage and though you said
as a thousand dollar pays a thousand
dollar payment or not no it's not it's
five sixty eight on your first in about
340 360 under he bought I will not end
your loan it until you achieve some of
your other baby steps that we talked
about here make sure you're out of debt
everything but the house make sure you
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses then and only then
would I pay extra on that yeah then you
dig out of this house mortgage after
that but no we don't cash out 401ks
unless it's to avoid a foreclosure or
bankruptcy because the penalties and the
taxes are so I and that's the reason
thanks for the call